did i talk about why my apartment
smelled like [ __ ] for like the first two
months
your current apartment yeah why not oh
yeah
like literal [ __ ] or like literal [ __ ]
yeah so
i you know i moved into this apartment
building and i like i something just
kept smelling weird i couldn't put my
finger on it right and i'm like
wondering the [ __ ] is this thing i
turned the ac off right yeah it's still
coming in my apartment still smells like
[ __ ] this is bran brand new i just got
this place why does it smell of [ __ ]
it's not me i'm i'm definitely flashing
looks down like covered in [ __ ] i'm i'm
i fart but like it's not that kind of
it's like a lingering like yeah i am i
i'm i'm i'm getting this right so
i i go to my balcony right and there's
like bird [ __ ] and i'm like well it
can't be there because i clean it and
and it and it still smells like [ __ ] i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah why
does it smell of [ __ ]
turns out
that there was this one place where
these birds were [ __ ] that was like
the intake fan was right here and all
the birds were just [ __ ]
right next to the intake
and i couldn't see it because it's like
it's like right next like there's this
much gap between the roof and the box
they're [ __ ]
it's literal perfect size for one pigeon
to fit in yeah and they loved loved
[ __ ] there i don't know why they
loved it maybe because they they felt
like the roof was closed it was nice you
basically were huffing and burning i
literally for two months was just
huffing in and i'm pretty sure that like
pigeon poop is like one of the poops you
don't want to be breathing in i think
any people i don't want to breathe in
anything to be honest as in i think they
have like one of the more
dirty
poops out there i believe uh i don't
know if this is correct
uh but let's say compared to one
compared
is there a poop scale of like hygiene
quality
i think it's i think it's just like all
poop right surely i'm sure when i was
like when i googled like cleaning pigeon
poop there's a bunch of things that are
like warning please make sure you don't
actually touch the poop because it it's
like filled with like disgusting
parasites and stuff when isn't it filled
with disgusting germs i play mine all
the time and it's not that bad
i could have been generic warning anyway
so i i cleaned it and then i was like
great this is amazing it's all fixed my
family doesn't smell of [ __ ] two days
later i start smelling [ __ ] again they
just kept coming back
i'm so
i then had to install like those spikes
on it oh yeah yeah to get rid of it and
finally now my apartment doesn't smell
of [ __ ] unless i leave the door open and
take a [ __ ] then it does smell
i was gonna i was gonna ask how you've
sorted the problem because like my
apartment is a my balcony is like a joke
it's like half reflective now i've put
reflective stuff everywhere and it
doesn't stop them
yeah because i i i noticed that because
uh in my house and in my home in
thailand it's like on the outskirts of
the city so it's more next like nature's
the nature side of things and i noticed
the spikes do [ __ ] nothing man that
the spikes the spikes is a great place
for birds to start a nest so like really
yeah these are like comically large
spikes okay okay okay i literally don't
get any birds on my balcony you're so
lucky how does that work i don't know
how do pigeons decide
this is the building but i'm gonna [ __ ]
up
maybe one pigeon is like oi
check it out yeah cause sometimes we
come on come on we sometimes get like
that one [ __ ] pigeon that's hanging
out outside the toilet yeah this office
and i can [ __ ] hear it because i
don't know why like
it's like it's here and in thailand as
well
the first thing i hear when i wake up
it's just these birds going at each
other like it's it's not even that right
it's not even pigeon sometimes it's just
like
sometimes i i swear she's just like
like it's the [ __ ] ghetto of the
birds right and i can just hear like oil
mate what are you doing here what are
you doing here man
bruv bravo what are you doing i'm just
every [ __ ] morning i don't know what
it is
um and we so we installed spikes to try
and stop these birds from like hanging
out outside like stop them loitering
yeah stop the use of loitering outside
of the spikes
i was just like the plastic spikes it's
just like it's just like that maybe just
plastic and they just didn't do anything
i know but like we thought okay we're
gonna we're gonna install them to stop
the birds like hanging out here every
morning uh it did the entire [ __ ]
opposite because now they they like
found out that spikes are great for
propping up a nest there so they just
they just blew a nest there so we we
literally helped them settle down at
that point you just got to give them
credit that's just that's just
impressive
um so yeah unfortunately i'd rather the
birds though because like in australia
we i would wake up to just like possums
[ __ ] on our roof what does that sound
like it just sounds it's just like a lot
of like rattling like this and a lot of
like
and like at like two in the morning i'm
like oh my god please stop that sounds
pretty good no it's not how does that
sound good
do they make a mess
i hope not well if you hope no that
means you don't know right so that means
they probably don't make it i mean the
mess is like half of the problem it's
the fact that i can't get to sleep
because of these plots
i'd rather have trouble sleeping than
have to clean this [ __ ] up every like
two months yeah i just
it's awful like they [ __ ] on my ikea
furniture as well thank you oh because
you got furniture on your
balcony as well so
wherever i put like the reflective stuff
down
they just move
and then i put like the reflective stuff
right above what is the reflective stuff
it's like uh like cds what's those um
uh the the colossoscopes no what are
they called
that's it sorry yeah the kaleidoscopes
like kind of patterns that reflect
and it just scares them off yeah but
sometimes it doesn't but some and then
other times they just like it's like
they're edging they'll like find a spot
and they'll have one foot on and they'll
just start [ __ ] off of it and i'm
like how am i supposed to predict this
this is insane that was a different very
different edging to whatever
[Music]
like they usually
it's such a pain in the ass
yeah because
do you ever have to deal like with like
annoying wildlife in the uk no i feel
like the most have any wildlife in the
uk i feel like okay the most annoying
thing for me in the uk is i don't know
if you have it in wales uh but in the
city in brighton at least or at least
when i was living in london as well
foxes the sound that they make sometimes
at night just is like the
like is the worst screech i've ever
heard
yeah we do have foxes yeah it's a deadly
sound what we have yeah the [ __ ]
[ __ ] though yeah because like
you make like eye contact with them they
run they're already like down the road
yeah yeah yeah you're lagging it down a
month yeah i used to live above uh like
a bunch of restaurants so always saw
foxes but they never made noise
they never made noise not actually they
never make noise if they're in the
vicinity of like guys or humans but like
for some you i would sometimes hear them
just like screeching off in like the
background and they literally sound like
i know like a kid being assaulted or
something right because i remember the
first time sydney like moved to england
she heard this noise and she was about
to phone the police i was like no sydney
that's just a fox because it just sounds
like at least
like you just heard that in the
background right and i'm just like the
first time i heard it i was like what is
that noise at least that's what they
told you
trust
that's just the door with like plastic
gloves on yeah it's the foxes it's the
foxes yeah
yeah i don't know we only had ends get
hands
that would get into the house they're
just they're pretty good ants are
they're really good they're getting into
your house yeah yeah but they're like
british ants are tiny though like
[ __ ]
can they even be called ants
when there's a lot of them yeah but like
that's the problem with it
yeah you're the restaurant ants don't
travel solo they're not like [ __ ]
words they're not like you don't see a
single land in your house and you're
like oh [ __ ]
they're normally like they're very kind
their ants they they have a nice line
that directs you to exactly where they
came from they're really really
considerate in that sense but they'd get
into like the bread bin and stuff and
they'd get into like yeah
[Music]
you think you've like sealed that bread
box up like tight i can't find where the
snacks are hidden in my house sometimes
yeah so i have to follow the trailer my
parents just hide them but the answer
would always find them they'd always
they'd always
i'd never really had such a big ad
problem in the uk it was more when i was
in thailand
where you live yeah yeah because like
when i was whenever i'm in thailand if
you have like a piece of food out or you
drop like a tiny bit of crumb or
something there's like a timer starts
right before you have that time the
timer starts before you can clean it up
otherwise the ants are going to clean up
for you and then you just kind of a line
of ants just marching through your home
yeah and like the thing about thai ants
is that they're the fruit they're pretty
[ __ ] big as well i'd rather be big
though easier to kill
no no no you know
it's like a super villain you know when
you step on an end yeah and it doesn't
die and you're like what this is how
like the villains feel the movies when
they're there doesn't work what do you
mean my attack fails
but like in in the uk like ants are just
a slight annoyance because what the [ __ ]
can they do to you right they're just
like eat your food like make it like
yeah slight annoyance it's a slight
annoyance that's very big annoyance
right like like they don't bite you or
anything like something i'd rather than
bite me than take my food really sure
have you ever been bitten by anyone
yeah yeah i don't think you'll say the
same way
i'm not like the [ __ ] what's that guy
called on youtube coyote peterson
not those kind of ants where he's like
he's like while my hand has swollen 19
times the original size i could scarcely
breathe but uh this is uh mildly painful
even if it's something like you know
even if it's not like toxic or like it's
super painful it's that is that is more
of an annoyance than the ants no i know
if it was a mild pain i'd rather that
than have to like what if it's like a
lot of mild pains because it's like a
lot lots of miles a lot of mild a lot of
mild people what does that mean i don't
know because you're not going to give
can you give me an example of a lot of
mild pain well because you know there is
can you give me another example because
you're not gonna because when an ad
bites you that just invites the other
ants to also attack what's going on i'm
gonna give them a second chance like
you never know
what is this
oh that hurt another another please
again yes one more time
put them on my nipples please bite me
again